finally we get to discuss new mutants
i'm so excited yeah i'm so excited for
people to see it
i know it was i'm not gonna lie i'm
starting to feel like a myth for a
minute
yeah no no for for me as well like uh
yeah absolutely
and i want everybody to go see it i just
want them to see it when it's safe to go
back to theaters
for sure well i mean there's been a lot
of talk about people being like oh man
just like release
new mutants digitally like how would you
feel about that how would you like to
see it come out at this point just
because we don't
know when we're going back i i truly
don't have kind of anything to do with
that part of it in terms of how they
want to release it is up to disney to
decide but i'd be happy with whatever
whatever medium gets everybody who wants
to see it the chance to finally be able
to see it
this isn't a hospital it's a cage i
wrote this with my very best friend who
i've known since the day i was born our
moms are best friends so we have like
pictures of us when we were little
infants together but uh
we grew up in the 1980s and read marvel
comics religiously and the way that we
kind of learned how to tell stories was
uh
we'd go get the new issue of spider-man
and we'd actually perform it onto a boom
box and just like pretend we were all
the characters and all that uh
so we've just been such huge uh comic
book fans for so long and uh
once i had made the fault in our stars
uh i knew fox obviously had the rights
to all the x-men stuff and uh
i had long loved uh new mutants because
it was so much uh
darker and more character driven than
some other
x-men stuff was for me personally uh and
it really was so different it felt like
it could
uh be very different from any other
comic book movie just in terms of the
aesthetic the way that it looked
uh the way we dove into characters and
everything uh
so in that way it's sort of not that
different from the fault in our stars
and even stuck in love my first movie or
the stand that i just made
it's all still kind of goes back to
character and performance and this one
is certainly much more so like that
than a typical comic book movie would be
i think
it has all the stuff fans want but it's
also got a bunch of other stuff as well
yeah well this one seems like it takes
place in maybe
one location or just a few so you kind
of the character has to be the most
important element right
yeah it's in a very contained setting
and i mean you know we shot all this on
a real location and that just
already gives it a very different feel
from a typical typical x-men movie or a
typical uh
marvel movie because uh there weren't uh
very few huge sets constructed so it
just all starts to feel a little more
grounded naturally by doing it that way
right well the trailer got a really big
reaction for
the horror elements and people were
really jazzed about that and there were
a lot of reports that maybe the the
movie shifted a little more into horror
so how would you describe the tone of
this movie is it like a why a meets
horror kind of thing
yeah i mean it's it's exactly kind of
what we sold them and went to go make we
never were able to do any reshoots or
any pickups because the merger happened
and the next thing i knew you know was a
year later and i'm at disney and they
said would you come get everything
finished and i went and finished my cut
finish the visual effects so uh there
was really just sort of a stop gap for
about a year
um and then came back and finished it
but i mean i would say that it has
horror elements but it's also a love
story i wouldn't say that it's not i
mean the spine of it is very much uh
blue and maisy's relationship and it's
also very much kind of a
story about friendship uh in that way it
is sort of john hughes a little bit a
little joss whedon buffy crew i love
that stuff so uh
just tried to sprinkle all those little
tones in that i like and hope
that uh it would fit well uh these
characters that we
were lucky enough to be able to borrow
from uh the marvel universe
yeah well you you mentioned the all the
reports about the reshoots that weren't
real and there was just a lot of like
there was i was just saying there was a
lot of like public talk about the behind
the scenes of this movie so just to
clarify because it was delays
yeah uh how much has how much would you
say this movie has changed over time
from when
you initially shot it so now when it's
coming out well
it really is still the same film uh
all that we did was it had been about a
year since i looked at it when nate and
i were able to go back and open it up
again and start working on it to get it
ready for release uh
so you know we did a couple little
tweaks here and there that were just
things that naturally occurred to us
watching it with kind of a break of the
year
but the story never changed at all it's
always been the same thing that we rode
and went and shot the first time uh
most movies do go reshoot stuff almost
every single one of them so i'd be the
first to say if we did because
it's sort of normal but uh we were never
able to reshoot so uh
you're seeing the result of the one
shoot that we did with nothing
additional from
later when the the the merger was
announced what went through your mind
did you think
this movie may never see the light of
day like how did you know i
i was never worried that the movie
wouldn't come out i just was like
it was just really unfortunate because
uh it was unfortunate for every movie at
the time at fox i think but uh
it was unfortunate because really fox
had no idea
what was going to happen the movie had
already been done
they'd been finished and they put for
sure their money and their time into
completing the big 200 million dollar
dark phoenix
ours was so much cheaper than that and
so much smaller than that that uh
it just i'm sure took a position of less
importance but uh
it also too is just not like these other
movies so uh
that one probably felt like more of the
one uh
to focus on because of the cast and
everything else i mean that's just
honestly uh
i don't think it was anything personal
against ours we always uh
had test screenings where people loved
the movie and uh
always had people who watched it and
felt it was very different from other
comic book movies so i'm just really
excited for people to see it uh
uh i'm very happy with it i got to
deliver the movie that i wanted to make
and nobody bothered me
so that's kind of uh the best case
scenario
yeah well i i read that you had sequels
in mind for this
i mean is do you think that's something
that could still happen at this time or
do you think
i mean i just i have no idea about
anything really the world's in such a
strange place right now uh
i i mean i sold it to fox nate and i
made them kind of a digital
comic book utilizing all these frames
from the comics that we loved and kind
of designing
you know a three movie three movie kind
of trilogy where each one would be a
different kind of horror movie
second one was going to be an alien
invasion movie about the character
warlock
third one was going to dive into the
x-men crossover series from the 80s
inferno
and this was of course all designed and
came up with before the merger happened
so
really think about it much after that or
beyond that yeah well i do think that
marvel has been quite infamous about
listening to the fans
so i feel like if the demands there like
the possibilities are endless especially
now that you would have more characters
at your disposal
if something went yeah and you know the
script for a very long time had warlock
in it
about six months before we went to go
make it we really had to cut the budget
in half uh to be able to go get it made
so we lost a lot of stuff we love we'd
love to see obviously in a later movie
i'm sure the cast would love to come
back we'd all love to go make another
one uh
but you know whether that happens or not
is sort of up to the uh the movie gods
yeah you mentioned disney gods
you mentioned you mentioned uh a certain
relationship kind of being at the center
of this movie in the comic book uh
rain and danny have sort of a telepathic
relationship which gives them
a lot more intimacy than uh than a
typical relationship in the film would
be uh
that just naturally became sort of what
it became uh
we don't really focus on it uh is being
a gay relationship it's just a
relationship that naturally develops
over the course of the movie but uh
i'm proud of it because i haven't seen
it in a comic book movie yet in a real
way where it wasn't background
well i i mean it's just like when you
see the articles where like
you know there was like a gay couple
that kissed at the end of star wars like
to me that's not
uh i don't know and it's you know i'd
say there's multiple movies that are
like that but uh
in this genre in comic book movies uh
i'm not saying that we're first but i
think that we
did i mean if it had come out earlier we
certainly would have been first but uh
i think we do explore a real
relationship between two teenagers in a
way that's not typically done in a comic
book movie
i want to do a quick breakdown of these
characters because we're kind of meeting
them for the first time so we have
maisie williams she's reign sinclair
she's probably the closest to me
personally because i was raised by
quite extreme evangelical christians
baptists in uh virginia when i was a kid
and rain uh
has a lot of uh personal issues and
problems because of her
religious upbringing so uh you know her
her power is basically she's sort of
werewolfy uh
but uh you know it's it's uh so much
more something she's sort of been taught
to be ashamed of
uh through her religious upbringing and
all that
we have annie taylor joy who has that
amazing soul sword she's our badass
she is uh well you know she's the one
who sort of comes ready made to already
be a superhero she's done a lot more
than they had than these other kids have
in the reality of the movie uh so um
her powers just lend themselves more to
that you know but she has also again
uh we tried to go make there be you know
real psychological dimensions to all the
powers so it's like
her powers are sort of directly related
to childhood abuse and uh
a bad situation that she was in when she
was a kid where
to escape this childhood abuse she would
go to this place in her mind called
limbo
and kind of over time her powers of
imagination made that place become a
real place
um and uh yeah so that's she has a
complex and interesting power which is
she sort of created her own kingdom
where she is a god there of of sorts of
goddess of sorts
i killed 18 men one by
one charlie heaton as sam guthrie
aka cannonball you know and again uh his
his power you know all these kids who
are in this institute who were in i said
the institute which it's like before
uh this stephen king book came out sort
of after this came out but like
sort of like fire starter in that same
way where people with special powers are
kind of kept in a place
uh they're all there because something
horrible happened when they used their
powers for the first time whether it was
intentionally or not
so you know charlie comes from a
working-class background in kentucky
where he worked in a coal mine with his
dad and a terrible accident happened
because of his power so he comes to that
place uh
he comes to where they're staying really
with a lot of shame and a lot of guilt
so all his power is sort of something he
keeps inside of him
that when it comes out it's really like
an explosion because
he keeps it buried so deep and then we
have alice braga
so she uh you know is really the
character that we borrowed
who doesn't appear in this actual run of
comics that we based the movie on but we
needed a character
to serve the purpose and we felt she
would really be the right character to
use
um so you know i can only say so much
about her she had a very
complicated role because you are
uncertain as an audience member and as
various characters in the movie as to
what it is exactly that she's up to
during all of it
so uh she's playing very much close to
the hip uh
and interacting with them all on an
individual basis differently from person
to person so uh
i'll just say she's sort of a mysterious
character and even what her powers are
are sort of left for later in the film
blue hunt
yes uh i mean you know she is the star
of this movie and she really is the star
of this arc of the comics where they
deal with her demon bear story uh
you know she we had never done a movie
before and we really wanted someone with
a real connection deeply to uh native
american uh
culture and tribe uh so we couldn't have
made this movie without her we saw
hundreds of people and she was
without a doubt the person that we
wanted in it the way we cast blue
uh it was really important to us just
like it was important that henry be from
brazil
you know we really wanted to try to get
some of those things as right as we
could possibly do and still make the
movie be really good
uh and you know blue having a real
relationship with a tribe that's family
you know part of her family and
everything
was a big thing for us for her to bring
as much authenticity to that role as she
could
she has a very complicated power where
you know in our narrative she sort of is
uh
is there because of her power but she's
not quite aware yet
she has a power or what it is that she's
doing it's all unconscious
so a lot of the movieists are having to
deal with and face this power that she
has uh
that has wreaked a lot of havoc and hurt
a lot of people
unbeknownst to her uh but hers is very
much
kind of a a rubber reality horror power
where she's able to sort of bring your
greatest fears to life
oh oh great i think uh stink nightmare
and upstream three the dream warriors
and you'll be close to sort of uh
one of our kind of touchstone movies
that we were inspired by when we wrote
it
yeah i'm noticing a lot of influence
here and now you're working with
stephen king on the stand so this is
like seems pretty perfect
yeah i directed the first and the last
episode of that and he wrote the last
one it should be very cool i hope people
like it
oh man congrats on that we're we're
viacom cbs so we're
we're in the family now all right well
hey thank you so much for your time
uh i really like your movie i hope that
you like it
[Music]